hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in his short work
on fate where Cicero is concerned with
the question of determinism causality
and human freedom one of the key
positions that Cicero is going to
examine is the epicurean one they are a
very important school of his own time
and he's going to target Epicurus
explicitly now he has access to texts
that unfortunately we ourselves don't
possess but we can reconstruct what the
epicurean position was from what he's
saying here and what he's saying is very
consistent with other sources discussing
the Epicureans Epicurus himself which
many people probably know from ethics as
a hedonist philosopher in terms of his
metaphysics was an animist so he's in
that tradition along with Democritus and
perhaps
lo khipus and his school in fact adopted
atom ism as its fundamental
understanding of the natural world and
thereby also of the human psyche which
is what we're concerned with
here and Epicurus taking this theory
over from Democritus made a few
adjustments to it now what is the atomic
theory the atoms simply mean the things
that cannot be cut any further so
whatever the smallest particles of
matter are they were materialists those
are constantly falling in a void so
gravity is one of the main forces of the
universe affecting everything and those
atoms come together into complexes and
affect each other causally so they're
all falling they wind up in certain
systematic causal connections with each
other they also impact each other and
produce effects in that way and now this
is a rather crude way of trying to
understand the universe but but it
really works if if we take away perhaps
the falling or some of these other
aspects of it and we ignore the fact
that Epicurus didn't have access to the
natural science of our own time there's
a certain plausibility to this and
Epicurus saw very clearly
according to Cicero that there would be
some fatalistic implications to this
mechanistic atomic theory that's
essentially materialist saying that
everything that we experience everything
that exists is just atoms within the
void put together in certain
combinations and engaging with each
other in certain ways now those ways are
regular so that means that if they are
put together in a certain manner that's
going to produce the same effect it's
going to cause something that we can
distinguish perhaps if it's something
visual or taste wise it's going to
produce the same effect every single
time now if you extend this to the
entire universe you get a completely
fatalistic determined universe
don't you and Cicero says that Epicurus
brought in a new element to the theory
he says the reason why Epicurus brought
in this theory was his fear that if the
atom was always carried along by the
natural and necessary force of gravity
and the impact all these other things we
should have no freedom whatever
since the movement of the mind was
controlled by the movement of the atom
and he also says the author of the
atomic theory Democritus preferred to
accept the view that all events are
caused by necessity rather than deprive
the atoms of their natural motions so
Epicurus is innovating and his grand
innovation is what we call the swerve
there is a declination a turning aside
and again it helps if you do visualize
all the atoms as falling in the void now
where are they falling towards there is
no actual place but just imagine all the
atoms proceeding in the same path and
every then once in a while one of those
atoms turns aside and it collides with
other atoms and it produces a new
combination and in that moment when
there's the swerve something new comes
into being or something escapes the
bounds of a fatalistic determinism or a
necessity
something that escapes the ordering of
things comes back into the ordering of
things and things act causally after
that so even though there is this moment
of change it's not as if everything
becomes totally random but what does
this do it introduces a certain measure
of randomness a randomness that is
unpredictable
you can't even decide just when and why
and Adam will swerve aside at this point
rather than at this point why this Adam
rather than that Adam so there is a
genuine randomness there isn't there
what we nowadays call indeterminacy you
could say there's a whole range of
possible ways the atom could swerve and
maybe those are limited right but you
don't know which one it's going to go
into it's not yet determined once it
actually does slide over here and
collide with this other atom over here
or connect up with it okay now that is
determined but how it's going to go
which one it's going to hook up with
that isn't determined so what this gives
us is you could say on a micro-level
over and over and over again is an
escape from fatality and escape from
fate and in Epicurus is view this is
what gives us genuine freedom now Cicero
has some problems with this as do some
other authors we brings in particular
cardio days the academic philosopher one
of the biggest problems with this is
Cicero says this is actually incoherent
because we want to have some sort of
causal account of things that can
provide us with intelligibility to the
universe as well as to our own
decision-making and all of that
so the swerve is problematic because the
swerve itself takes place without any
cause that's why you can't predict it
because there is no cause for the swerve
and Cicero
you know raises several different issues
and problems for this he says that this
this is actually a big issue for the
Epicureans why this swerve why not more
swerves why not all sorts of other
things along these these lines he says
this really is not helping us to explain
anything later on he'll say
the atom does swerve Epicurus says in
the first place what causes the swerve
for the motive force they will get from
Democritus is a different one a driving
force turned by him a blow from you
Epicurus they will get the force of
gravity or wait what fresh cause
therefore exist in nature to make the
atom swerve or do the atoms cast lots
among themselves which is to swerve and
which not or to swerve is the reason for
their making a very small swerve and not
a large one or for their making one very
small swerving at two or three swerves
and he concludes this is actually
wishful thinking not investigation of
the natural world this is just making
something up this is providing an
explanation that doesn't really explain
anything but this has been an attractive
way of reintroducing freedom into a
deterministic universe for many people
as we'll talk about in just a moment
there is a bigger problem however
Epicurus not only has something that is
escaping causality by seemingly
suspending causality altogether at
particular moments and doesn't seem to
be very intelligible but this is
supposed to explain human freedom and
this swerving of atoms really does not
yield us distinctively human freedom the
freedom of the will the volum toss here
in Cicero it doesn't give us a freedom
of our own movements of our mind
something that Aristotle himself already
noted in calling us self movers
something that Cicero is going to hold
on to something that Carney ha days the
academic skeptic who he's talking about
here thinks is absolutely essential
something that even the stoic
cruciferous wants to hold on to as well
even though cruciferous wants to have a
deterministic universe and wants to
our willings determined and yet in a
certain sense also chosen by us and free
and within our power does Epicurus get
us anything remotely like this no we
just have randomness at a very low level
in some respect this is similar to
people in our own time who want to say
that the the indeterminacy at a micro
level shown to us by various physical
theories like quantum mechanics somehow
yields us freedom of the will when
really freedom of the will would have to
be something at a much higher level
something that we can distinctively
relate to and say AHA I experienced that
that's something that I work with I
think that other people have that mere
randomness is not the same thing as
freedom and as Cicero points out the
reason why this is the case is because
if we want to talk about any anything
like freedom of the mind or freedom of
the will that is not being completely
determined by fate or a necessity or
whatever else it is that we think is is
completely controlling things then we
have to look at it in terms of our own
self-determination we have to be Clauses
and we're not going to get causes out of
an account that is in effect saying
causes are suspended every so often but
at this very low level we're not getting
causes in the sense that we actually
need here to have a true account of
human freedom so Cicero is rejecting
this account on two main grounds one is
that the swerve itself seems to be
unintelligible it doesn't really make
sense it seems to be sort of a made-up
hypothesis just to get Epicurus out of
trouble but it doesn't even achieve what
it's supposed to do in the the account
that he's able to provide so this is
Cicero's critical analysis of epic
on freedom and fate
you